so first of all you have to figure out
where that that's occurring and then you
have to consider that we have a muscle
tube it's cartilage and muscle and
tissues right here in our throats right
we need to be working this out as well
and by working out that too but you can
expand it and you can actually reduce
and sometimes reverse your sleep apnea
okay so how do you work out that tube
[Music]
welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
episode 116 with james nester the
breathing expert
do people really need to learn how to
breathe apparently when i was really ill
i felt like i couldn't inhale fully all
the time but my diet fixed that there is
more you can do though if you have
trouble sleeping or sleep apnea this
episode is for you we got majorly
sidetracked down topics like freediving
which was fun james is awesome i am most
definitely trying freediving we spoke
about the health care system sleep free
diving some hippie stuff the usual
i'm a huge fan of this guy this was a
fun episode if you enjoy it please
remember to hit subscribe also side note
if you want to sponsor this show hit me
up if you have awesome products that i
like that is no vegan shakes i like meat
and honey and air fryers and grills and
salt and things i can sleep at on or sit
on
or maybe free diving equipment just
kidding you don't need anything to free
dive except your breath
hit up sponsorships at
michaelapedersen.com link below i hope
you enjoyed this episode
james nestor welcome to my podcast
thanks a lot for having me
before we get started would you mind
giving my audience a brief background if
they don't know who you are of who you
are and what it is you do
sure i'm a science journalist and an
author and i write about
health or i have been for the last few
years and i'm interested in the
potential of the human body that's what
seems to be a through line through a lot
of my work
okay so i
specifically wanted to speak with you
because my dad's been diagnosed with
sleep apnea rather severely he was
waking up like maybe 30 times
like a ridiculous amount he had no deep
sleep and it was ruining his life
one of the things that was so
i thought let's get sleep apnea out of
the way and then let's talk about other
aspects of breathing but a lot of people
suffer from sleep apnea and i know one
of the ways to reduce the suffering is
to lose weight
but
are there other ways to go about
reducing sleep apnea and is cpap the
right way to go so what are your
thoughts on that so sleep apnea is this
huge problem and it just seems to be
getting worse and worse every year so
about 20 of the population suffers from
some level of sleep apnea which is crazy
and a lot of people think that sleep
apnea only afflicts obese people because
what happens is too much fat accumulates
around their necks and their airways get
clogged and they start choking on
themselves throughout the night but
that's not true so many people who are
average weight or even underweight
ultra marathoners
top fitness people can suffer from sleep
apnea as well so sleep apnea is a
problem in the airway and that problem
can occur in various areas of the airway
so
for a lot of people it's the tongue
falling back uh
into the mouth sometimes it there's a
problem with the oral pharynx
nasopharynx that the deal is there is an
obstruction there that has to be cleared
and for so long people who had sleep
apnea were often misdiagnosed and so
they were giving given a whole you know
battery of different pharmaceuticals
which was actually making their sleeping
worse if you don't do anything with your
sleep apnea after several months or
several years it can lead to so many
chronic very serious problems diabetes
has been linked directly with sleep
apnea yeah
who knew adhd alzheimer's all the rest
so
i'm not a doctor i can't prescribe a
blanket fix for everyone with sleep
apnea the most important thing is
is to get it diagnosed figure out
exactly where the problem is
then you can fix it so
okay that's that's interesting so
i didn't realize that there were
different that sleep apnea could be
caused by different problems
so yeah can you delve a bit more into
that
sure so
you know people who are obese suffer
from uh sleep apnea again because they
have too much too much fat around their
necks but the same thing happens with
weight lifters
you figure these people who are weight
lifters are the fittest people on the
planet but they die of heart issues all
the time in their 40s and 50s because
they have so many muscles around their
necks and it inhibits their ability to
breathe which is why so many people who
are very fit have a lot of musculature
around their necks have sleep apnea
so first of all you have to figure out
where that that's occurring and then you
have to consider that we have a muscle
tube it's cartilage and muscle and
tissues
right here in our throats right we need
to be working this out as well and by
working out that too but you can expand
it and you can actually reduce and
sometimes reverse your sleep apnea
okay so how do you work out that tube
mouth workouts
yeah as as idiotic as that sounds i'm
not going to demonstrate because it's
it's gross but there's something called
oral pharyngeal exercises that have been
found in a few studies to be very
effective in reducing sleep apnea
surgery can be very beneficial as well
and cpap is great as a band-aid right
and it absolutely works it's been a
lifesaver for so many people it's doing
nothing for the core issue of sleep
apnea to be pushing air into your body
for a third of your life
is not a good in my opinion a good
long-term solution
so there's there's so many different
ways of treating this
again i'm not going to be the one to
tell people how to treat this but i will
give you a few little hints from what
i've heard from experts in the field
from harvard from stanford and more is
they prefer to start softly and see what
your natural body can do for yourself
and then you can lead up to a full
diagnosis and and go into surgery or
other methods to help
fix that
okay interesting so people potentially
not that this is medical advice but
potentially suffering from sleep apnea
if they're using a cpap or something
like that they could look into some of
these mouth exercises and just see what
it does for them if that ends up
changing any of their symptoms they can
do a few things they can do these oral
pharyngeal exercises there is one
instructure
instructor that helps people uh improve
their sleep apnea outcomes by singing
and which is basically work out for your
mouth that's cool and you get to sing if
you're tone deaf that might be a problem
for people around you but
and there are also different things you
can do with breathing in the daytime and
this is a burgeoning area of research
what they're finding is if you can
control your breathing and breathe
better in the day you can influence how
you're breathing at night and this
sounded sketchy when i first heard it a
couple years ago tell i've more more
recently heard from some top level
researchers who are exploring this in
some studies right now
that makes sense
that if you practice something during
the day you strengthen those muscles and
then slowly you teach your body to
breathe a certain way at night that
makes sense
yeah and that's that's the thing with
all these little hacks is
there's not too much of a leap of logic
to get there you're like okay my mouth
is flabby uh just like other areas of my
body are flabby what happens when i
don't exercise them they get out of
shape what happens when i exercise them
they can get toned up what happens when
i breathe in a slower lighter way in the
day i'm gonna carry that habit into the
night and and so to me it seems pretty
simple and yet who's talking about this
stuff i just don't see too many people
except for for some leading researchers
you know
in in academic institutions
okay so a flabby mouth how does one know
whether or not they either have a floppy
mouth or their breathing is is improper
what are the signs
yeah well that's that's tough uh if
you're snoring then there is room for
improvement and oftentimes not always
but snoring and sleep apnea go hand in
hand and a lot of us continue
uh to believe that snoring is like this
cute thing uh we think oh my you know my
husband my wife snores i have to sleep
in another room haha but but snoring is
so injurious to the body if you're
struggling to do anything
for a third of your life
struggling to get air right um it's it
it can cause so many downstream problems
and we've known this for for decades and
decades and still you go on youtube and
see pictures of like infants snoring and
people think it's cute and it's you know
talk to people in sleep medicine about
how cute that is later on in their life
when they have developmental problems so
it's it's very serious stuff
okay so back to weight lifters then
you said that what they need to do is
start focusing on also working out
those muscles is it also reducing the
amount of muscle they have around their
neck though or
no i i think it's less a concern about
that and more concern about your airway
health
and
the things that i'm suggesting now i
want to be perfectly clear i'm not
saying this is going to work for
everyone all the time it's going to cure
all your problems but this stuff is free
you will only be celebrating in benefits
of having better breathing right and
having better airway health you can only
benefit from this so so why not look
into it so those exercises they're
having weight lifters do and and skinny
people and ultra marathoners do are
you're using this very powerful muscle
which is your tongue
and you're learning how to use the
tongue the way our ancestors use their
tongue in in the fact that they used to
push their tongues to the roof of your
of the mouth when you're swallowing
right and we know this because our
ancestors all had these pronatic faces
right they all had straight teeth
because they had these wide mouths they
got those wide mouths by having this
correct oral posture
so so it starts with that oral posture
don't walk around with your mouth open
when you swallow
move the tongue to the roof of the mouth
to push it don't push against your teeth
right
and if you want you can do some of these
oral pharyngeal exercises which are a
whole bunch of crazy stuff opening your
mouth lifting the tongue to the top of
the mouth sticking the tongue out so on
and so forth
what does any of this have anything to
do with mewing have you heard of mewing
so mewing is just uh that's just a
version of an oral pharyngeal exercise
there's really no difference between it
and what what john and mike have done is
they've tried to bring
awareness to the fact that our oral
posture is so poor and if you have poor
oral posture
when you're young it can affect the
growth of your face it can actually
affect how you're breathing later on in
life because as the face develops right
it needs the right inputs about 40 to 50
percent of how you look of how your
airways are going to form are epigenetic
which means they're going to be formed
by whatever inputs you put into them
it's it's not just encoded in your genes
right it's it's the environment that is
influencing how you're going to look and
how you're going to be able to breathe
and so what they were trying to bring
awareness to
was to shut your mouth for one don't
walk around like this
you see a kid walking around like this
that's bad news right
shut your mouth the teeth should almost
be touching and the tongue should be on
the roof of the mouth with the very tip
just grazing the back of your front
teeth
so a lot of us even when we're shutting
our mouths
our tongues are still down low
tongue should be raised up and you're
gonna notice
when you open your mouth the tongue
tends to rock back into the throat right
that it helps to to close the airway
when you close your mouth that tongue
will rock up and will help open the
airway this is especially important at
night when you've got gravity working
against you just shut your mouth and
become a nasal breather
okay very aware of my tongue at the
moment it doesn't make for a very good
radio does it to just be sitting there
with your with your mouth closed working
on these exercises but listeners you can
try this at home and see how it works
for you
yeah i've got i've got a bit of a horror
story i'm so horrified by this i have a
four-year-old
and they put warnings on soothers right
it's like don't use this past six months
and
i was young and
she liked her soother so i was like
she likes the soother anyway she's about
a year she's past a year and she still
had this soother and my mom
was like you're screwing up her teeth i
was like i'm not screwing up her teeth
and and but then i started looking into
it and i was googling and it was just
hundreds of pictures of these toddlers
with teeth that have grown like around a
soother and then they end up with their
lower jaw that's too far back and it's
and it destroys how attractive they are
which is a huge problem when you grow up
they end up with a whole bunch of teeth
problems like jaw surgery if it's really
bad so obviously we stopped the soother
and but it took her teeth
maybe almost two years
to go back to normal it was horrifying i
was very unhappy that
they don't have these huge warnings on
soothers like we'll disfigure for life
if you use these too long but does
soother use or sucking your thumb when
you're little
does that screw up breathing as well
of course it does yeah for sure
and you know there's a lot of research
i'm not an expert in this field about
baby-led weaning about not using this
non-nutritive
uh suckers um or pacifiers
you know a lot of people were saying i
was just hanging out with dr kevin boyd
last week who was the expert in this
field and he's saying like anything over
six months for with a pacifier is bad
news he even says any pacifiers are are
bad news because what what happens is
when an infant is is breastfeeding and
and breastfeeding every two hours or how
however often it helps to literally pull
the face outward okay when you're
pulling the face outward the palate will
become will be able to sink down and
open up and so you not only have this
more attractive pronatic profile but you
have more room in the mouth for teeth to
grow in straight
so you're setting up the foundation
for straight teeth and also a wider
airway what happens when you have a
wider larger mouth you have a wider
airway there's more room in there and so
one of the reasons why so many of us
suffer from snoring and sleep apnea is
our mouths have grown too small and
because they're too small there's not
enough room for our tongues and so we're
literally choking on ourselves
every night because of this and and it
this sounds crazy but all you have to do
is look back at ancient skulls this is
something i did for a couple of years
worked with with some top researchers
they all had stray teeth they all had
pronatic
profiles right they had these wide nasal
apertures they breathed totally
different than we do today
it's amazing how many ways you can screw
up just being alive
like oops pacifier
it's like under a year and a half and
your face is screwed up now
well
you know the good thing is that's
reversible you're aware of it now and
there's so many procedures you can do
expansion procedures correct oral
posture all of these things can make an
incredible
difference to the profile to the
breathing health of your kid it's about
establishing positive habits now
as you know when we're in early
development it's much easier to change
these screw-ups when you get to middle
age right it's a lot harder because
things are more set that doesn't mean we
can't make a lot of improvements and i
showed that in in my book you know
two-year airway health to your breathing
to your health um obviously we can but
it's a lot easier when you're younger
okay but when you're middle-aged you can
still
do you think doing those these facial
exercises not for everybody but for some
people or losing weight doing the facial
exercise and strengthening can reverse
sleep apnea
for some people
for some people uh yes it can and and i
know this because i've seen it
because i've this is the one thing i've
heard more from from anybody else um or
people with snoring and sleep apnea
who have written have adopted these
quick little fixes who use a little bit
of sleep tape at night and no longer
snore no longer have sleep apnea doesn't
work for everybody but it's worked for
according to these people thousands and
thousands of people and now there's a
study booting up at stanford with 200
people looking at nasal breathing and
sleep apnea on how just nasal breathing
changing the pathway through which we
breathe at night can significantly
improve our sleep and reduce sleep apnea
interesting i always had a i had a
number of health problems and i always
had trouble
i used to snore i don't anymore but i
used to snore but it's because i
couldn't breathe through my nose at
night it felt like i couldn't breathe
through my nose and then i fixed my diet
now i can breathe through my nose and so
now i don't snore anymore but
sleep tape always horrified me a little
bit when my nose was stuffy because i
was like i remember thinking if i ever
get kidnapped
and they duct tape my mouth i'm gonna
die
because i can't breathe through my nose
very well so
do do people who have trouble breathing
through their nose are they able to do
the sleep tape does that improve do you
think it does improve it but it again it
depends what's what's your problem
what is causing this nasal congestion
right is it a structural issue have you
broken your nose four times your septum
so so deviated you can't move through
your nose
or is it an allergic reaction to food to
something in the environment to
something in the air
um
you know so each of these things has to
be looked at and you need to find the
core issue that's that's causing the
problem in order to really fix it
so as you found and so many other people
have found changing your diet can
significantly
impact your ability to breathe through
your nose especially removing dairy
especially us dairy a1 protein dairy can
make a huge difference
um for other people it's it's about
finding what else is causing that
allergic reaction right is it pollen
um so so you have to look into that but
the key is here that if you are a mouth
breather i'm more convinced of this now
than ever and i'd heard this from
researchers years ago if you're a mouth
beer there you are never ever really
going to be healthy no matter what you
do no matter what exercise you do no
matter what foods you eat you have to
become a habitual nasal breather this is
the route through which the body wants
to receive air because when we breathe
air through the nose it's filtered it's
pressure pressurized it's humidified
it's conditioned when we breathe air
through the mouth
you can think about the lungs as an
external organ they're exposed to
everything in the environment if you're
breathing 20 25 000 times a day
you're gonna really cause a lot of
problems and you're gonna overwork your
body unnecessarily
okay that makes sense yeah especially
air filtering that makes sense you don't
have to fight off infections without
that kind of
mucous membrane protection
yeah that makes sense uh okay
what's a proper breath look like like if
you're describing to the audience
exactly how you should be breathing you
talked a little bit about where your
tongue should be but is there a length
of time you're supposed to breathe in
versus out like what does a normal
breath assuming you're not exercising
look like it depends who you are and it
depends on what you're doing so the
perfect breath is the breath that is
most efficient to your metabolic needs
you don't want to be over breathing for
your metabolic needs you don't want to
be under breathing so kids need to
breathe more than adults
when you're jogging or running you're
gonna be breathing more than you're
breathing on a sofa right
it's easier said than done to say just
breathe within your metabolic needs but
one thing the nose is so good at is it
helps control
the flow of air into our bodies and it
does this for us in many capacities
it's really hard to hyperventilate
through the nose
it's really easy to hyperventilate
through the mouth which is why you see
people with anxiety fear-based disorders
panic asthma they tend to breathe like
this
yeah try to do that through your nose
it's a lot harder so when you breathe
through the nose you're forcing your
body to breathe more slowly to breathe
more deeply and breathe more lightly
and those slower fluid breaths allow us
to get more oxygen
with fewer breaths and so that's what
efficiency is all about if you're into
athletic performance it's all about
efficiency right
so many of us don't think about this
that we think it's okay just to be
breathing up to our into our upper chest
just all day but that's just like
revving a a car
and idling just over and over and over
you're working your body you're working
all these different functions but you're
getting a minimal amount of breath
so one good thing that i one good breath
that i learned four people at rest okay
this isn't gonna work if you're boxing
is to take in a breath of about five to
six seconds in
and five to six seconds out
so when you breathe this way that
you shouldn't push it okay a lot of
westerners tend to just that seems like
such a long time well this is an
exercise uh you're not going to be able
to do this throughout the day if you can
my understanding is you're only going to
have benefits from it but this is an
exercise to condition yourself
to slow it down
and it turns out that when you breathe
this way
so many different systems of the body
enter into a state called coherence your
brain waves enter the state of coherence
your cardiorespiratory system enters the
state of coherence
heart rate goes down blood pressure goes
down more oxygen is delivered to the
brain more areas of the brain come
online are able to communicate more
fluidly just by breathing this way if
you have a wearable that can look at
heart rate variability everyone's into
that stuff nowadays check out what
happens to your heart rate variability
when you breathe in this pattern of
about
five to six seconds in
five to six seconds out
five to six seconds in and five to six
seconds out so this this is not a
placebo effect and you can see it with
very clear objective measurements from
instruments
and so this is a great place to start uh
there's only benefits from breathing
this way if some people get panicked
when they're breathing this way and
can't do it
just slow it down you know do do four
seconds in and four seconds out and you
should think of this breathing like like
a circle don't think of it like ah
that's good for pranayama martial arts
stuff but this calm breathing should be
very relaxing to you and you can use
this anytime you want to calm yourself
and the science is very clear that it
has pretty profound benefits
oh that's that seems fairly simple five
to six seconds in five to six second
notes how do you feel about something
like wim hof breathing
i love wim hof breathing i think wim is
an amazing dude i think he has brought
awareness to the potential of breathing
what it can do for autoimmune issues
what it can do for anxiety what it can
do for fitness freaks and bros and women
and whomever else
more than anyone and i i'm lucky enough
to have spoken with him several times
and i'm a huge fan of of what he's doing
it seems so counterintuitive that he's
up on a stage right saying breathe
everybody let's go
and i just told you that the most
benefits are going to be from this very
slow breathing
but
it depends on what you want your breath
to do for you
wim hof's method which is an ancient
method and he's the first to admit that
is like going to the gym you're not
going to spend 24 hours in the gym right
you go in for a very closed amount of
time you work your body out get jacked
up and then you feel better for the rest
of the day
so his method
teaches you how to
turn on stress that's what it's doing
you're stressing yourself out you
probably think why do i want to stress
myself out you want to do that so that
you can learn how to turn it off you
compound all your day's stress in 20
minutes and then the rest of the day you
can chill out and that's why his method
is so effective what people don't see
about whim is when he's not up on stage
you know shirtless yelling at people to
breathe more he's chilling out breathing
through his nose breathing very lightly
and softly but but that's not uh you
know it's not as sexy as seeing a dude
on stage in front of an audience doing
that so what i'm saying is breathing you
can do it in all of these different ways
and there are there are benefits to be
had from so many of them
interesting i found with wim hof i used
to do a lot of you know head space or
meditation just trying to calm my brain
down and i found that that i've never
experienced anything as effective as his
breathing if you do like three rounds of
30 of those really intense breaths it's
very unpleasant i find but the after
effect is just insane like i had no idea
that breath could make that much of a
difference to
mental health or just your sense of calm
it makes sense but
still that that method of breathing very
heavy and then holding your breath and
then breathing very heavy again this has
been around for thousands of years
there's so many pranayamas that do this
sudarshan kriya does the exact same
thing kundalini breathwork does the
exact same thing and it's no coincidence
that all of these different techniques
affect us in the same way they're so
effective for anxiety and panic there's
a hundred independent studies looking at
sudarshan cree and how effective it is
even for autoimmune diseases
when people are constantly stressed out
you know there's this iv drip of
adrenaline and cortisol you have to stop
that and by breathing this way as as you
know and as i know it allows you to sort
of get it all out and then just be so
relaxed through
the rest of the day what what i love
about this stuff too is it's free
you know and there are no negative side
effects to to breathing so it's
accessible to everybody and and i think
that that's that makes it so uh
it makes it so universal which is why
the hindus were into this and the
ancient chinese were into it and we're
into it today
good
so your book took off right like you
i've seen you on a ton of different
podcasts people seem to be
really interested in this do you have
any idea
why
your book's been so successful
that's a good question i have no idea
when you when you write books you know
you put them out into the world and you
think maybe your mom and friends are
going to read them and
that might be it it's a scary thing
because
you have no idea what's going to happen
i certainly had no idea what was gonna
happen with this book you know i when i
first mentioned the idea to my agent and
editor they thought it was the stupidest
book idea they'd ever heard so i had to
work on it more i said i think there's
something in here they didn't believe
these stories that you could help fix
scoliosis with breathing that you could
help fix asthma with breathing that you
could fix panic with breathing um that
diabetes
could be uh
symptoms of diabetes could be reduced
with breathing they didn't believe this
and and i didn't believe it uh either
until i really spent a long time years
talking with researchers and putting
together the stories so
i was unfortunate enough to have spent
so many years working on this book and
it was all printed and ready to come out
in
may of 2020 and as you know books books
are printed like five months ahead of
time
right so it's in the warehouse ready to
go it was already released in catalogs i
was ready to tour
march comes around of 2020 i was like oh
my god so i had to record the audiobook
in in a shed in my backyard because
everything was shut down here in san
francisco
we weren't going to release the book we
were going to wait a year a year and a
half and then an editor said you know
what people might need this right now we
have a respiratory pandemic and uh i
said what the hell i'll just i'll do
promo the next year we'll just get it
out and uh
yeah it's been a complete trip you know
the last year and in a couple of months
have have been pretty nutty uh i didn't
know that so many people were as
interested in this seemingly simple and
and odd thing as breathing as as as i've
seen but obviously it's awesome i'm so
grateful
i guess that makes sense given the
pandemic have you done any research on
how breathing can affect
and
covet or viral
issues
it can have a huge impact on it and this
isn't from my experience this is coming
from doctors in the field there's a
whole group of doctors called
stasis right now they put together
breathing protocols for covid
so one of the first things they started
doing with covid patients is instead of
having them on their backs
right in hospitals
most of the expansion in your lungs
happens in your back it doesn't happen
in your chest everyone thinks it's here
oh wow
when you breathe it's happening in your
back so if you're on your back
it's much harder to even take a breath
in right
and we've known this for hundreds and
hundreds of years and yet in hospitals
they're laying out these coveted
patients on their backs so the first
thing they did
is started to prone them they would lay
them on their stomachs or their sides
and it made a huge difference
then they started noticing that so many
people suffering from severe covet had
breathing problems they were mouth
breathing they were breathing too much
they were constantly hyperventilating so
they started fixing that then they
started engaging the rest of their lungs
right this is a viral
problem in the lungs and it
seeps into all of the different lung
tissues and clogs them up right
what you want to do is to be engaging
the other parts of the lungs that aren't
clogged up with fluid
and to be breathing more fluidly
to be breathing very softly and lightly
into the lungs so this can make a huge
difference and i was
pretty amazed that i was finding this
and researchers were writing me right
when the book came out and said try to
get this information out there and yet i
just don't see the cdc or anyone else
talking about nutrition vitamin d levels
breathing health
you know when it comes to covid
treatment and
i think they should and at least from
what i've heard from several doctors
that should have been a part of the
program uh right from the get-go
yeah it most certainly should have
but
i don't know why maybe it's harder
i think the medical community is so used
to looking into pharmaceutical
interventions
that it's just a little bit outside of
their forte
maybe
i don't know
yeah it should have obviously been
covered
it is outside of their forte because
they're dealing with acute severe
problems you know in my family there are
doctors my father-in-law is a
pulmonologist so the specialist of the
lungs and so much of what i was finding
he had never heard of in his life and
and you know he was curious as to why
that was but he's dealing with people
who come in with lung disease who come
in get in a car accident who have copd
right he's not dealing with people who
have chronic low-grade problems a lot of
doctors say we only deal with the
walking dead you have to get so bad just
like with sleep apnea you can have five
apnea events six acne events
per hour and you still won't get any
treatment from sleep apnea it has to get
so bad before you get treatment for it
and i just think that that is a twisted
way of looking at human health like
maybe we should be looking into
prevention and what we can do to avoid
these long-term problems
yeah i entirely agree but the problem
there is there's so many aspects
nowadays that are wrong aspects of our
lives that are just wrong like you have
to
you have to attack it in such a
multifaceted way that it's hard to say
you know fix this one part when
when for for people to be healthy they
need to fix you know nutrition and sleep
and exercise and breathing
and how your mouth is developed and
breastfeeding it's a lot to handle just
to keep somebody healthy it it is but as
we've been discussing here these fixes
are so like well of course oh it's so
simple right that they're not very
convoluted and the way i look at this
stuff because diet is more confusing now
than it's ever been it doesn't need to
be that confusing it's the further we
move away from nature the sicker we get
if you look at any culture if you look
at at westerners 300 years ago the
advent of the industrial revolution
right
this is when all of these chronic
diseases first started taking root
so when we start moving away from nature
and it's no coincidence that if you look
at the hunter-gatherer tribes that are
still around
they don't have hypertension they don't
have diabetes they don't have
asthma they don't have allergies they
don't have any of these the vast
majority of these problems that we have
and yet their diets are some of them eat
the majority of carbs that's what their
diet is 90 carbs others eat almost
entirely fat and meat and cow's blood
but they still don't have any of these
problems so to me i start seeing these
patterns the further we move away from
that the sicker we get what happens when
we start moving back towards nature and
doing things our bodies were evolved to
do oh that's weird our bodies start
getting well again and this is this is
how i view a lot of of medicine is
moving in this direction because it's
been so effective for people who haven't
been helped in any other way
i hope so i think that from my
experience from get being chronically
ill to healing was like i didn't stop i
mean i still haven't stopped talking
about it and i didn't stop talking about
it for a number of years to everyone i
met because i was so mind blown that i
had control over some of my health
problems so i think everybody who clues
into one of these kind of
alternative health practices isn't even
the right way of of talking about it
because it's more like traditional right
but i think the more people that clue
into it the more it'll spread and with
social media and podcasting and
everything it seems to be going in a
positive direction i hope and hopefully
that'll influence mainstream medicine at
some point
yeah i hope but but it's also it's so
strange to me that you've got all these
dudes in the gym now talking about the
electron transport chain and atp and
they become default biochemists you had
to do your own research right you're
like nothing's working for me i need to
do my own research here i had the same
exact experience with breathing i said
why do i have all these respiratory
problems my doctor and other people are
like oh you're old dude get get used to
it and i was like yeah but you can see
these older people who don't have any of
these respiratory problems so so
something's wrong it's just all of us
have been forced to become
these hackers in such a way where we
have to research our own core problem
because no one else is doing it but in
some ways that's it's enlightening that
so many of us now have access to
information to take control
of our health you know and i don't think
that this information was disseminated
before
you know it was much harder to get this
10 years ago 20 years ago now we have
podcasts and other routes of finding
information and you can try this stuff
out and see what works for you
yeah that's the nice thing about it just
listen to people try it out see see what
works so you said i wanted to ask you
and i forgot to ask you uh closer to the
beginning of the episode why did you get
into this in the first place
uh i had some breathing issues but i'm a
science journalist so i didn't want to
write a memoir about that that's that's
not my jam and so i just sort of stuck
with those and i was curious as to why i
was having them i surfed a lot here in
san francisco i was also doing a lot of
martial arts at the time and i kept
getting bronchitis and i kept getting
mild ammonia like every single year it
would get pneumonia i noticed i was
starting to weasel it a little bit when
i was working out um you know
my doctor's office they gave me a
bronchodilator and said uh just use this
when you're wheezing i was like well
what's the core problem they're like i
don't know
you know just and i said well that's
weird i want to research this a bit so i
stuck with that and i tried to figure it
out for a couple of years i went to a
breathing class
which i was told could help improve my
lung function and instead i had just
this absolutely crazy reaction
from doing this very vigorous breathing
it's just like wim hof breathing but
it's like 50 minutes long of really
going for it yeah
yeah
and i just started sweating just pouring
sweating profusely my my hair was like
sopping wet i sweat through my t-shirt
and i went back to my friends who are in
medicine i said what what happened they
said oh you had a fever
oh the room was too hot oh you were
wearing too many clothes i said no no
those things were true but still i
didn't know what to do with that story
so i put that in the back file and kept
researching breathing and then was put
on an assignment to write about free
divers for outside magazines this was
years and years ago
and i saw them and they just opened
everything up they were doing something
that's supposed to be medically
scientifically impossible and they're
doing it every day so if they can do
that what else can we doing could we be
doing and what else can i learn about
where breathing can take us
that totally makes sense so
besides stepping into free diving
do they do some do they prepare similar
to wim hof i know that if i do wim hof
breathing for about
10 minutes like the the cycles of 30
breaths i can hold my breath no problem
for like three and a half or four
minutes which you shouldn't be able to
do and i can most definitely do and it
didn't take a lot of practice to be able
to get there so do they do something
like that in order to be able to free
drive how does that work it's very
controversial stuff here so some people
do
but the reason you're able to hold your
breaths for so long after you
hyperventilate like that is you're
offloading a ton of co2 from your body
right
and by offloading that co2 you are
allowing your
chemoreceptors to to reset and have more
time before they trigger the need to
breathe this gets a little complicated
i'll simplify it so the need to breathe
is not triggered by oxygen
it's triggered by an increase of co2 so
if you exhale and hold your breath
and then you're like i need to breathe
that's triggered by an increase of co2
if you're breathing very slowly and hold
your breath you're gonna have a healthy
balance of co2 which means that limit
right that difference be between that
need to breathe is going to be smaller
if you offload
more co2 you have more space there
before those those alerts go off
so this can get dangerous because co2
and oxygen are very closely tied
together that need to breathe when that
co2 gets to a certain level is usually
the time when your body needs oxygen
so if you're hyperventilating before
you're diving you can pass out because
you can run out of oxygen before that
trigger
of co2 hits those chemoreceptors
oh that's not what i wanted to hear at
all i'm sorry yeah so don't ever do wim
hof in a bathtub don't ever do it before
you go into a pool
people have died doing this that is do
it on your sofa you know do it on land
so with free diving what you really want
to train yourself to do
is to naturally be able to accept that
increase of co2 and that
you can breathe slowly most
all of the freedivers are met they
breathe very slow before they dive
they'll breathe a big breath but it'll
be a slow and calm breath to calm
themselves down it's a lot harder to
hold your breath that way at the
beginning but this is the better way of
free diving
wow
i had no idea i'm also glad you told me
about the bathtub because i can see
that's a way i could have gone gone out
like well i can hold my breath forever
don't don't
if you're if you're even if you're
hyperventilating and holding your breath
for four minutes you'd be a good free
diver because you've a mat you've
enabled your body to become comfortable
with that long breath hold and i i can
tell you like free diving
is the most transcendent meditative
thing you can do have you done that
all the time yeah really favorite thing
so a lot of people view freediving you
you go on youtube and you see guillermo
neary uh diving down to 300 feet right
or with sperm whales and
so he's an elite diver this is uh it's
kind of sad my first book deep there was
some free diving in it that looked at
the human
uh body and our connection to the ocean
from the very surface of the of the
ocean to the very bottom of the deepest
sea right so there's freediving up in
the more shallow levels but
a lot of people know freediving through
its competitions where these people are
challenging one one another to see how
deep they can dive and come back to the
surface conscious yeah what could go
wrong
well i i saw what could go wrong and
that's that's in the outside magazine
article
but free diving that's that's not what
it was originally intended to be and
that's not what the vast majority of the
people on the planet use it for they use
it as this connection with the ocean
with yourself it's totally silent down
there you're in zero g's you're floating
around animals come up to you because
you're silent they accept you as part of
their you know the ocean environment so
it's just such a trippy and amazing
thing and uh it's been hard being locked
here in san francisco but i'm traveling
very soon and i hope to be doing a lot
of diving in the future
that sounds amazing i haven't done very
much looking into that gave me
goosebumps that story that sounds that
sounds amazing where are you planning on
going are you gonna go somewhere and and
do the free diving i'm going to europe
for a couple of months so they have free
diving pools in italy and in france i've
been to the one in paris where instead
of the pools being like wide and shallow
they're very narrow and deep so you can
practice there they go down to about 60
i think the one in italy goes down to
100 feet so you can practice your free
diving in this controlled environment
because free diving is a huge deal in
europe not just the competitive side but
people do this because they're you know
it's it's the easiest way to really
connect with yourself and to force
yourself into a meditative state you
can't do it if you're anxious or panicky
or hyperventilating you have to chill
the hell down
and to focus and just sort of let your
body go and uh you will never feel
better than you have after
four or five hours of free diving in the
ocean because not only are you
experiencing that you're breathing in
this very fluid controlled way
okay i'm sold how long can you i'm
definitely going to do that how long can
you go for
how long do you hold your breath for
you're asking me these very clear
questions i realize i'm giving you the
most convoluted answers but uh there's a
reason i'm doing that so freedivers told
me
don't pay attention to your watch the
reason is your body changes from day to
day
so you could be feeling really good and
stay down to three to four minutes or
some days you're a little stressed out
you ate the wrong foods and your body is
telling you to go up to the surface
after two minutes so
we are so inherently competitive western
ours westerners are that that we just
want to be looking at oh i made it you
know three minutes yesterday i'm gonna
try to go four
listen to your body like leave that crap
behind and
when you feel the need to breathe here's
an idea go up to the surface and get a
breath this is not a competition this is
about enjoying yourself and connecting
with your body so having said that other
people have have timed me and i've done
very shallow
um you know dives for about three
minutes three or four minutes that's not
moving a lot right that's just sort of
sitting sitting down and the more you
move the more oxygen you're using so but
even a minute underwater and even diving
down to 60 or 70 feet at around 30 feet
buoyancy shifts and you no longer get
pulled to the surface you get gently
tugged
to the deep that's creepy and you it's
not it's it's when you first do it
you're like whoa because you're you're
just like a feather floating down
but you can just sit there unmoving and
float down and just glide down
so just staying down for a minute is a
transformational experience and feeling
that negative buoyancy that gravity-less
state
it's just incredible so i hope i'm i'm
really selling this big time to people
to do this
in a responsible way don't practice this
crap in your bathtub get a proper
teacher and do it the right way and uh i
think it's a really beautiful hobby to
do
cool okay well i'm i'm definitely
interested in that
uh i guess to practice then you'd want
to stay more shallow so you could get
used to the breathing slowly
sounds scary if you're floating down and
then you also like suddenly realize you
need a breath and then it's harder to
get back up because the buoyancy's
you have to think of it like climbing a
mountain right
you don't climb a mountain and think as
you're going up i'm going to use 100 of
my energy you have to use about 40 of
your energy
you know 50 and say i always need to
have something in the tank
so with a proper free diving instructor
you're gonna go down to seven feet okay
you're gonna get comfortable with seven
feet then you're gonna go back up
then after a while you're gonna go down
to 10 feet and then 15 feet and then 20
feet so you will know your halfway limit
that's what free diving is all about
just like so many other things you you
will feel that your body tells you all
of these messages because
we are meant to be in the water deep
diving humans have something called a
mammalian dive reflex it's the same
reflexes that dolphins and whales and
seals have
we have them too and the deeper you go
the less of a terrestrial animal you
become because more of these reflexes
kick in your spleen releases oxygenated
blood into your bloodstream and and
blood comes into your core and your mind
enters this meditative state some free
divers have recorded their heart rates
at seven beats per minute during deep
dives and this is the body
learning that you're relearning
becoming reacquainted with these ancient
skills that we're all born with and when
they start turning on it's gonna freak
you out but it also feels incredible
because you feel like you're really
connecting with with our our true nature
again
that is so cool seven beats per minute
what
isn't it versus like 90 something
what do we normally add well it depends
at rest a lot of people can be in their
60s uh some athletes can get into their
50s and 40s right now we're talking
we're active we're probably in our in
our 70s or 80s
so so this is not supposed to be humanly
possible and they've read they've looked
at their blood oxygen levels and found
that they were at 50 percent 5-0
what is considered unhealthy is below
92.
so uh this was a recent study too and
they've been studying this for decades
but a study came out a couple months ago
showing this again shouldn't be
possible if you told someone this was
possible and and hadn't done the study
they they would call you insane and yet
this is the stuff that that i love it's
like
if we don't know this about our bodies
if we're just discovering this what what
else is out there what else can we do
with them
i completely agree that's kind of how i
feel i've been on only eating meat since
december 2017 for autoimmune issues
again completely mind blowing like how
is that possible didn't think that was
possible i like this free diving thing
so people are basically we still have
those old mammalian instincts
but we just forgot about them yeah we're
all born with them um and what we do is
just reawaken them when we enter the
water and you can you don't have to free
dive to do this the reason why if you go
into your kitchen or your bathroom right
now
and splash cool water on your face
your heart rate can go down about 20
percent just by doing this because that
triggers these nerves in your face to
send messages to your body to calm down
so those messages increase the deeper
and deeper you go when your body senses
pressure when it senses your whole body
is in water it calms us down and this
calming us down allows us to conserve
more oxygen this is why a whale can stay
under water for 90 minutes why seal can
stay underwater for two hours they're
accessing these mammalian dive reflexes
they also have different hemoglobin
profiles but
but we have these things too we're
mammals you know um and we're just like
seals and just like dolphins and just
like whales in this regard which is why
when you free dive
these animals if you're lucky enough to
have them around
they accept you as is one of their own
and they they come up to you and they
interact with you i've had these these
interactions and it's just the most
incredible experience you could have
because with scuba you're pretty loud
right you look like and you look
terrifying you look terrifying and they
associate dolphins at least
associate
bubbles with signs of aggression that's
what they do yeah when they're being
aggressive but if you come up and they
see you go up to the surface grab a
breath of air just like they do and then
you come back down and then they start
mimicking you in what you're doing
and it's a beautiful thing people i know
this sounds like some new age dream but
but go and do it and you'll see for
yourself
this is exactly right down my alley that
sounds perfect
okay
that was awesome uh where can people
find you online if they want to learn
more about
breathing and breath work and apparently
free diving
so my website my publisher allowed me to
to put all of the scientific references
there's something like 400 scientific
studies because i realized all of this
sounds
just like complete sketchiness and uh
but it's all real uh so you can see that
at mr
mrjamesnester.com
backslash breath to go right to that
portal
there are videos up there there are
interviews with professors at harvard
and other leaders in the field talking
about breathing there are also exercises
all of that is is free for people um the
larger stu
story is in the book of course i'm
trying to get better at this instagram
thing pretty bad at it but i'm just
posting stuff associated with the stuff
i'm working on
uh breathing and other elements of human
potential
cool that was amazing i'm gonna get my
dad into these mouth exercises he's like
he's he's already on a diet he's like
what more what more is there michaela
like haha mouth exercises now dad is he
is he uh sleep taping by any chance
he
was i don't think he is anymore he had
an autoimmune flare-up
and that is under control again now
so he's back into all the things to make
himself feel better and i think focusing
on the
sleep apnea right now would be good
which is part of the reason i invited
you on so thank you for all that
incredibly valuable information
more than happy to help thanks a lot
thanks a lot for having
[Music]
you